***
Exorzismus.
Bei dem Thema
habe ich diese Bilder vor Augen.
Ein dunkler Raum,
ein gefesseltes Kind.
Und ein Priester,
der mit dem Satan kämpft.
Um so krasser ist es,
dass die katholische Kirche
weiter Exorzisten beauftragt.
Es gibt sogar einen Exorzismus-Kurs.
Lernen die da wirklich das hier?
(beide)
The power of Christ compels you!
Und hilft ein Exorzismus
Betroffenen weiter?
Was am Horrorfilm-Mythos dran ist,
haben wir gecheckt.
*dynamische Musik*
Hallo, Jack Pop hier.
Exorzismen, also die Austreibung von
Geistern, Dämonen oder dem Teufel,
machen nur dann Schlagzeilen,
wenn etwas schiefgelaufen ist.
*Eine weibliche Stimme liest vor.*
Es gibt auch solche Bilder hier,
wo keine Verbrechen stattfinden.
Aber die Leute reagieren
ziemlich krass und emotional.
Bester Stoff für Horrorfilme!
Laufen alle Exorzismen so krass ab,
wie uns das in Filmen gezeigt wird?
Und schadet so ein Exorzismus
den Betroffenen?
Oder kann er evtl.
zur Heilung beitragen?
Um das herauszufinden,
haben wir mit allen Seiten geredet.
Mit einem katholischen Theologen,
mit einer Religionswissenschaftlerin
und einer Psychiaterin.
Wie im Film auch
starten wir hier mit den Besessenen.
*schrille Violin-Musik*
Meist sehen wir Frauen,
von denen der Teufel Besitz ergreift.
Er ändert allmählich ihr Verhalten.
Something is coming.
Something bad is gonna happen.
Das kann harmlos anfangen.
Sie starren vor sich hin
oder haben Gedächtnislücken.
Die Besessenen
werden später aber aggressiv.
*Poltern und Stöhnen*
I'll stop your heart, old man!
Deshalb wird ein katholischer
Priester zu Hilfe gerufen.
Der soll sich darum kümmern.
Bei uns in München gibt es
jedes Jahr mehrere Anfragen.
Meistens sind es Frauen,
die zu uns kommen.
Sie sagen, sie fühlen sich
bedroht und belastet von Dämonen.
Sie fühlen sich da verfolgt
und suchen Hilfe.
Axel Seegers leitet
den Bereich Weltanschauungsfragen
bei der Erzdiözese
München und Freising.
Immer wieder
fragen bei ihm Menschen an,
die glauben,
von Dämonen besessen zu sein.
Er nennt das:
- Belastet von Dämonen.
Die hängen da nun nicht an der Decke
oder drehen ihren Kopf um 360°.
Aber ihnen passieren
unheimliche Dinge,
die sie sich
nicht erklären können.
Ich kann mich
an eine ältere Dame erinnern.
Sie erzählte, dass es permanent
oben auf dem Speicher rumort hat.
Da waren irgendwelche Geräusche.
Es waren aber
keine Tiere o.Ä. festzustellen.
Eine andere Person
hat sich an mich gewandt und sagte,
dass sie permanent
Impulse erlebt, etwas zu tun,
was sie aber gar nicht tun möchte.
Für sie ist klar, das ist nicht sie,
sondern das kommt von außen.
Sowas schon erlebt,
mit oder ohne Dämonen und Teufel?
Aber unheimliche Situation,
die euch unerklärlich waren?
Schreibt es in die Kommentare.
(singend) I can't hear you.
Die katholische Kirche erhält
Hilfeersuche aus der ganzen Welt.
Nicht immer wird gleich
ein Exorzismus durchgeführt.
Aber er ermöglicht der Kirche,
mit diesen Anfragen umzugehen.
Was auf jeden Fall nicht stimmt:
Wenn der Priester
so einen Anruf erhält,
sprintet er sofort los.
In Wahrheit ist das
ein recht bürokratischer Akt.
Der kann sich
über mehrere Monate hinziehen.
Ein Exorzismus wie im Film
wird "großer Exorzismus" genannt.
Den darf nur
der zuständige Bischof erlauben.
Die Bedingungen dafür
wurden schwieriger.
Das liegt v.a. an einem
speziellen Fall aus Deutschland.
Der war Vorbild für den Film
"Der Exorzismus" von Emily Rose.
Der Fall der Studentin
Anneliese Michel in den 70er-Jahren.
Die Nachricht damals:
(Archiv) "Auch Pädagogikstudentin
Anneliese Michel war katholisch.
Sie starb am 01.07.
Todesursache lt. Obduktionsbefund:
Unterernährung.
Seit dem 24.09.1975
hatten 2 Priester versucht,
ihr mit dem großen Exorzismus
den Teufel auszutreiben."
67-mal haben Priester an Anneliese
einen großen Exorzismus durchgeführt!
U.a. weil sie Stimmen
aus der Hölle gehört hat.
Damals wurden auch
Sprachaufnahmen angefertigt.
Wir können mal kurz reinhören.
*Archivaufnahme*
*unverständliche
röchelnde Stimme im Wahn*
(Priester) "Im Namen
des dreifaltigen Gottes, ..."
*röchelnde Stimme*
(Priester)"... des Sohnes und
des Heiligen Geistes befehle ich ..."
*röchelnde Stimme*
Wie geht es euch?
Ich finde das mega "weird".
Das könnte 1:1
aus einem Horrorfilm kommen.
Nach diesen dramatischen Ritualen
ist Anneliese Michel
an Magersucht gestorben.
Mehrere medizinische Gutachten
bescheinigten nach ihrem Tod
neben ihrer bekannten Epilepsie
noch eine
paranoid-halluzinatorische Psychose.
Eine recht heftige
psychische Erkrankung!
Diese Diagnose hätte Anneliese
zu Lebzeiten evtl. helfen können,
eine angemessene Behandlung
zu finden.
Aber die Priester
und die strenggläubigen Eltern
holten keine medizinische Hilfe.
Obwohl sich Annelieses Zustand
ständig verschlechterte.
Am Ende wurden sie
genau dafür auch verurteilt.
Das sorgte für großen Wirbel
und öffentlichen Druck.
Die katholische Kirche
führte deshalb zuerst in Deutschland,
später weltweit ein:
Vor jedem großen Exorzismus findet
eine medizinische Abklärung statt.
Ob eine Abklärung auch
zu einer wirksamen Therapie führt,
lässt sich im Einzelfall
nur schwer überprüfen.
Der Fall von Anneliese Michel
wirkt bis heute noch nach.
Es gibt immer noch große Vorbehalte,
v.a. in Deutschland.
Das sieht man auch an den Zahlen,
wie oft ein Exorzismus stattfindet.
Dazu gibt es nämlich
unterschiedliche Aussagen.
Der große Exorzismus
wird meines Wissens
offiziell hier in Deutschland
überhaupt nicht gespendet.
Anders sieht das Nicole Bauer.
Die Religionswissenschaftlerin ist
Expertin für Exorzismus-Forschung.
Aus meiner Sicht stimmt das nicht.
Aufgrund meiner Forschung kann ich
auch mit großer Sicherheit sagen,
dass in Deutschland
auch in den letzten Jahren
große Exorzismen
durchgeführt wurden.
Das ist immer noch ein heißes Eisen.
Aber ob große Exorzismen nun in Dtl.
durchgeführt werden oder nicht:
Wenn sie durchgeführt werden,
dann geht man davon aus,
dass die betroffene Person
wirklich besessen ist.
Aber was heißt eigentlich "besessen"?
*schrille Violin-Musik*
Im Film sind die Anzeichen
für eine Besessenheit
immer klar definiert:
übernatürliche Kräfte,
heftige Verrenkungen
oder eine verstellte Stimme.
*verzerrte unverständliche Stimme*
Natürlich
reagiert der Dämon auf alles,
was der Priester tut ...
na ja, ungehalten.
Fuck him!
- Be gone!
Diese stereotypen Eigenschaften
sehen erst mal
nach Hollywood-Übertreibung aus.
Aber die katholische Kirche
hat handfeste Kriterien,
die eine Besessenheit definieren.
Die sind denen aus den Filmen
echt ähnlich.
Diese Kriterien
stehen seit Jahrhunderten
im "Rituale Romanum",
eine Art Handbuch.
Darin stehen bestimmte Abläufe,
z.B. für eine Taufe
oder eine Eheschließung.
Aber auch für einen Exorzismus.
Das Ganze wurde 1999
überarbeitet und angepasst.
Jetzt muss man vor einem Exorzismus
eine medizinische Abklärung machen.
Aber die Kriterien für
eine Besessenheit stehen noch drin.
Religionswissenschaftlerin
Nicole Bauer dazu:
Eine Aversion
gegen christliche Symbole
oder christliche Gegenstände.
Das Zeigen von übernatürlichen,
übermenschlichen Kräften.
Man kann plötzlich etwas tun,
das die eigenen Kräfte
vollkommen übersteigt.
Dann die Kenntnis vom Verborgenen.
Ich weiß also etwas, was ich
eigentlich nicht wissen kann.
Das Sprechen oder Erkennen fremder
Sprachen, die man nicht gelernt hat.
*Person zählt in fremder Sprache.*
*Sie singt etwas in fremder Sprache.*
What?
Diese Kriterien müssen gegeben sein,
damit ein Exorzismus
erbeten werden kann.
Im Film ist das easy.
Alle haben da diese Kriterien.
Denn jeder soll raffen,
dass sie besessen sind.
Als Erklärung wird natürlich
der Dämon herangezogen.
And I am Lucifer,
the devil in the flesh.
Für mich kommt ein Dämon
als Erklärung nicht infrage.
Ich habe gedacht,
die Symptome von Besessenheit
lassen sich medizinisch erklären.
Deshalb ordnet nun eine Psychiaterin
die gleichen Kriterien noch mal ein.
Ich habe es oft erlebt bei Menschen,
die leider
sexuellen Missbrauch erlebt haben.
Durch Kirchenvertreter.
Das ist kein seltenes Phänomen,
das ist recht häufig.
Und das ist
ein Trigger für Erlebtes.
Weil oft im Rahmen des Missbrauchs
religiöse Symbole verwendet wurden.
Dieses Phänomen
kennt jeder Psychiater,
der in der Akutpsychiatrie
gearbeitet hat
und zu tun hatte
mit akut psychotischen Menschen.
Diese Menschen entwickeln Kräfte.
Das würden sie im normalen Alltag
für unmöglich halten.
Zierliche Frauen
treten plötzlich eine Tür ein
oder werfen
einen Tisch durch den Raum.
Es ist offenbar ein Fähigkeit
des menschlichen Körpers,
in Situationen, in denen
man sich extrem bedroht fühlt,
solche Kräfte
mobilisieren zu können.
Diese Dinge sind also gut erklärbar.
Aber nicht bei allen
Besessenheits-Kriterien
ist das so easy.
2 Dinge kann die Expertin
nicht so locker einordnen.
In meiner beruflichen Tätigkeit
hatte ich mit Menschen zu tun,
die mir sagen, sie können
bestimmte Dinge spüren und sehen.
Und zu einem großen Prozentsatz
tritt das dann auch ein.
Das klingt etwas vage.
Auch deshalb,
weil Frau Roth-Sackenheim
nicht jede Aussage ihrer Patienten
auf den Wahrheitsgehalt überprüft.
Das ist für die Therapie
oft nicht wichtig.
Aber sie hat schon erlebt,
dass Menschen
von inneren Bildern sprechen.
Und in ihrem Gegenüber
etwas erkennen,
was sie eigentlich
nicht wissen können.
Evtl. kann man das noch erklären
mit guter Menschenkenntnis.
Aber beim letzten Kriterium
wird es schwieriger.
Ich persönlich habe es nicht erlebt.
Ich kenne keine Kollegen,
die es erlebt haben.
Aber die Berichte darüber
sind durchaus ernst zu nehmen.
Das kann man nicht abtun
als generellen Quatsch.
Von diesen Berichten
gibt es sehr viele.
Aber es gibt auch Versuche,
das zu erklären.
Z.B. dass gewisse Sprachprozesse
schon im Gehirn angelegt sind,
ohne dass wir darauf Zugriff haben
bei normalem Bewusstsein.
Aber 100%ig klären
kann Christa Roth-Sackenheim
das medizinisch nicht.
Was ich aber auch
irgendwie normal finde.
Denn um manche Forschungsfragen
endgültig zu klären,
braucht es noch Zeit
und wissenschaftliche Arbeit.
Aber dass es auf gewisse Fragen
noch keine Antwort gibt,
öffnet für Menschen
die Tür zum Übernatürlichen.
Für die ist ein Exorzismus
dann die logische Konsequenz.
Die Frage ist vielmehr:
Wenn jemand fest daran glaubt,
vom Teufel besessen zu sein,
schadet ein Exorzismus dann
oder kann er sogar helfen?
Im Film sieht das immer krass aus.
Da ist ein Kind in einem Zimmer.
Das nicht sehr kindgerecht
eingerichtet ist.
Es ist ans Bett gefesselt
oder wie hier auf einem Tisch.
Es krümmt sich und schreit.
Und hat lauter Brandwunden
vom Weihwasser.
Die Angehörigen
weinen entweder völlig aufgelöst.
Oder versuchen,
das Kind festzuhalten.
Oder werden wild
durchs Zimmer geschmissen.
*Schrei*
Dann ist da noch der Priester.
Der wirkt trotz Exorzismus-Erfahrung
gestresst
und manchmal fast ängstlich.
Der zuckt zurück,
wenn ihn der Dämon anschaut.
Und schreit die Gebete raus,
als wolle er das
schnell hinter sich bringen.
Es sieht nach einer
heftigen Erfahrung für alle aus.
Save your servant who trusts in you,
my God.
Be unto her, o Lord,
a fortified tower.
In the face of the enemy.
Das ist im Film
natürlich total übertrieben.
Fehler 1 ist der Ort.
Einen Exorzismus würde man nicht
bei jemandem zu Hause machen.
Exorzismen werden meist
in einer Kirche durchgeführt.
Oder in einer Sakristei.
Man sucht sich schon bewusst
einen heiligen Ort dafür aus.
Das Kinderzimmer ist also Quatsch.
Richtig ist aber,
dass Angehörige dabei sein dürfen.
Es sind nicht nur der Priester
und die betroffene Person.
Und bei Exorzismen an Frauen
muss eine weitere Frau
daran teilnehmen.
Die 2. Sache, die nicht stimmt,
ist, dass es so heftig abläuft.
Denn allein ausgehend
von dem Kirchen-Regelwerk
müsste ein Exorzismus
relativ harmlos ablaufen.
Der Exorzismus ist eingegliedert
in eine
gottesdienst-ähnliche Handlung.
In manchen Fällen wird vom Priester
ein kath. Gottesdienst abgehalten.
In dem ist dann
das Exorzismus-Ritual integriert.
Dieses Ritual ist
eine Aneinanderreihung von Gebeten.
Der Priester zeigt dabei das Kreuz
oder besprengt die Person
mit Weihwasser.
Oder legt die Hand auf.
Hier seht ihr das z.B.
beim Ex-Chefexorzisten des Vatikans.
In den Filmen sprechen die Priester
immer im Befehlston mit dem Teufel.
Show yourself!
Das ist heutzutage optional.
Man beschwört nicht mehr den Teufel,
sondern bittet Gott um Hilfe.
Aber was ist mit den Besessenen?
Der Klassiker "Der Exorzist"
endet z.B. gut,
zumindest für Reagan.
Sie ist nach der Tortur
wieder ein ganz normales Mädchen.
Wir können nicht absehen,
wie betroffene Personen reagieren,
wenn sie
an diese Besessenheit glauben.
Die Kirche suggeriert evtl.
im Ritual einer Person,
die einen krankhaften Wahn hat,
dass dieser real ist.
In Ländern wie Polen oder Frankreich
ist der Teufelsglaube schon groß.
Dort kommen Menschen
evtl. dadurch erst auf die Idee,
besessen zu sein.
Schadet der Exorzismus also?
I'm scared.
Nathalie, I'm here.
Problematisch wird es,
wenn der Exorzismus
der einzige Ausweg ist.
Bei einem Fall der Psychiaterin
Christa Roth-Sackenheim
hat der Exorzismus
definitiv geschadet.
Das hat letztlich dazu geführt,
dass die Dame
kurzzeitig psychisch entlastet war,
wenige Stunden.
Dann kam die Erkrankung
mit Wucht wieder.
Und es kam zum Suizid.
Nach dem Motto
"Ich bin so schlecht,
dass selbst der Exorzist
nicht half."
Das ist superheftig.
Aber das war ein krasser
und extremer Einzelfall.
Denn es gibt Situationen,
in denen religiöse Rituale
den Menschen
tatsächlich helfen können.
Ich hoffe, sehr religiöse Zuhörer
schreien jetzt nicht auf.
Für uns Psychiater
hat das viel zu tun
mit Selbstheilungskräfte aktivieren,
die der Mensch hat.
Die etwas
mit Autosuggestion zu tun haben.
Das ist überhaupt nicht
abwertend gemeint.
Beim Placebo-Effekt
haben Sie denselben Ansatz.
Das ist sehr hilfreich,
auch wenn wir nicht wissen,
warum.
Wie ein Mensch genau
auf Exorzismus reagiert,
hängt von vielen Faktoren ab
und muss immer neu bewertet werden.
Grundsätzlich kommen Menschen
mit religiösen Wahnvorstellungen
eher aus einem religiösen Umfeld.
Denn in einem Wahn
sind persönliche Erfahrungen
und Prägungen entscheidend.
Das Fazit der Psychiaterin
lautet:
Im besten Fall hilft das viel,
im schlimmsten Fall schadet es viel.
Es ist fast wie bei anderen
medizinischen Behandlungen.
Ein Exorzismus
ist kein Heilsbringer per se,
so wie die Filme
uns das oft suggerieren.
Er ist aber in der offiziellen Form
nicht so heftig und dramatisch,
wie wir das
automatisch im Kopf haben.
Meine Gesprächspartner*innen
waren sich einig:
Medizin und Religion
müssen Hand in Hand gehen,
wenn man den Betroffenen
wirklich helfen möchte.
Okay, das war ein ganz schöner Tanz
mit dem Teufel.
Hoffentlich habt ihr
nicht zu viel Angst bekommen.
Wenn wir es nüchtern
und rein wissenschaftlich betrachten,
dann muss man festhalten:
Es gibt keine Evidenz für Dämonen,
für den Teufel, Satan usw.
Wir hoffen,
dass ihr nach den Horrorbildern
noch ruhig schlafen könnt.
Wir sagen Danke an Axel Seegers,
Nicole Bauer
und Christa Roth-Sackenheim.
Sie haben uns sehr geholfen.
Abonniert bitte diesen Kanal
und drückt die Glocke.
Dann sehen wir uns bald wieder,
ich freue mich drauf.
Mehr schwachsinnige Folgen
gibt es hier drüben.
Willst du dir das
wirklich anschauen?
Ja, hab sogar den Kanal abonniert.
*schauriges Lachen*
Loser.
Hab sogar die große Glocke gedrückt.
Copyright UT: MDR 2023